good morning I'm really pleased to be
here to talk about the subject of my
latest book who is a man called Robert
hunter who was very active in the
progressive movement at the beginning of
the last century and actually pioneered
a number of very important social
reforms of that era including the first
child welfare a child labor laws
prohibiting employment of children in
factories mines and and in sweatshops
when in 1903 Robert hunter a social
worker from Indiana married Caroline
Phelps Stokes daughter one of the
richest men in America the national
press took notice the Phelps Stokes
family they also had a dodge connection
so they were the Phelps dodge Stokes
family had amassed several fortunes in
banking real estate railroads and mining
during the last half of the 19th century
and what came to be known as the Gilded
Age in America when it was revealed that
the young couple would forsake the
luxuries of their country mansion to
live in a slum neighborhood in New York
City - in order to continue their work
among the poor that had brought them
together it was front-page news
the decision of the hunters to join the
Socialist Party of America shortly
thereafter caused an even greater
sensation well much of the press
coverage of the young couple was
accurate the humble origins describe to
hunter were not really a true hunter
rather than being the portal lad from
rural Indiana that they reported almost
inferring that he was this rule
hick he actually came from a relatively
prosperous family and and one with a
reasonably respectable pedigree the fact
that he had chosen a career in social
work was a consequence of strong
altruistic impulses based on Christian
beliefs that he first sought to act upon
close to home in Indiana and later in an
ever-widening
marina hunter was born in 1874 in Terre
Haute his family owned a company that
manufactured horse horse-drawn carriages
his father served in the Civil War
rising to the rank of colonel and
Ulysses as grants at 21st Illinois
regiment after the war he settled in
Terre Haute and became active in local
and state politics most notably he
served out on the local welcoming
committee for Grover Cleveland when his
campaign for the presidency brought him
to Indiana in 1884 10 year-old Robert
Hunter wrote a white pony at the head of
the welcoming parade and was introduced
to the presidential candidate who in the
time-honored tradition of political
office seekers praised young Robert and
predicted that he he had a great future
ahead of him although he was often
critical of organized religion Hunter
was a committed Christian and took the
teachings of his faith seriously as he
noted in his memoirs the problem which
most deeply troubled me I found in the
Gospel of st. John which states for he
that loveth not his brother whom he has
seen how can he love God whom he has not
seen
he goes on to describe the
soul-searching process that he
experienced as he approached adulthood I
found it difficult to harmonize in my
mind my own acts and indeed the
practices of the clergy were the
teachings of Jesus how could I call
myself a Christian unless I really loved
others as myself as myself and shared
with those in need everything I
possessed this self-examination
eventually resulted in an abrupt and
dramatic transformation from contented
happy-go-lucky unreflective youth into a
serious young man totally committed to a
life of service to the poor a crucial
event of that time that seems to have
set him on the road to a Korean Social
Work and social reform was the
especially serious economic panic and
they called deep recessions Andreessen
depressions and those days panics that
struck the entire country in 1893
factories and businesses of all kinds
closed or dramatically reduced their
operations throwing millions of people
out of work
Chicago for example had just celebrated
its emergence as a major player in the
international marketplace by hosting a
World's Fair in April May of 1893 to
showcase its new economic muscle however
as Charles Fanning a chronicler of the
city's history observed that that sunny
spring of self-congratulation was
followed by the worst winter of poverty
homelessness and starvation in the
city's history the black winter of 1893
94
when thousands froze on the streets and
fought for sleeping space in the
corridors of City Hall Terre Haute
although a small town and a little far
away from Chicago was not immune from
these economic dislocations falling
prices caused the bankruptcy of many
previously prosperous farmers and local
businesses that depended on their trade
even those employers who survived
including Hunter's father were forced to
lay off large numbers of their workers
causing great hardship local charitable
organizations were overwhelmed with
requests for assistance from hungry
families Robert aged 19 at the time
volunteered to visit the homes of
unemployed workers and distribute food
to the needy what he witnesses in the
homes he visited shocked him he
recognized revelation for one one who
thought he knew well his small town to
discover the noisome unsanitary
conditions and pitiable pitiful
destitution of the starving families who
lived in the filthy streets and alleys
along the river and beyond the railroad
yards this experience generated in him
the Pharaon resolve to undertake a
lifelong quest to relieve the sufferings
of the poor
although hunters father had served as a
model of charity and personal generosity
firm Robert always standing ready to
respond to individuals in need and
support organized philanthropic causes
he was both astonished and alarmed when
his son announced his plan to devote his
life to working with the poor there was
no such profession at that time generous
people of means donated time and
to relief of the needy but the work did
not connect on stitute a career hunter
was expected to mentor the family
business or become a lawyer and he
briefly tested his talents and interest
in those areas however he remained
resolute in his plan and his encounters
with two prominent figures in the
emerging fields of scientific charity
and political economy convinced him that
he was on the right track
these were dr. Philip ears and professor
John R Collins when hunter first met him
Ayers was secretary of the Cincinnati
Bureau of charities and he invited
Robert to visit the organization
observed the work being done there and
discussed hunters interest in
undertaking charity work on a full-time
basis hunter was appalled by the awful
social conditions and desperate need
that he observed in the slums of since
Cincinnati and wanted instantly to
plunge into relief work however ears
convinced him that he was not yet
adequately prepared for such work and
encouraged him to enter Indiana
University there he should study
sociology economics and related subjects
with Professor Cummins an experience
that he would surely find interesting
and would also test his commitment to a
career in social work hunter follow
dears advice pursued a course of studies
under Commons and Verne confirmed his
career goals and diligently prepared
himself for employment as a social
worker immediately upon graduation from
Indiana University in 1896 hunter went
to work for years who was then
organizing secretary of the charity
organization Society in Chicago the
conditions under which ACOG owes poorest
residents had to survive in the best of
times
appalling what hunter arrived in the
midst of yet another serious and
prolonged economic downturn and was
shocked at the sheer mac n numbers and
dire need of the unemployed workers and
the families who needed assistance he
was given responsibility for running a
relief office near the stockyards an
especially poor area of the city as he
noted later I spent most of my time
visiting the families who applied for
aid and mentally spiritually and
emotionally I was continually affected
by the conditions at but confronted
while engaged in this relief work in
Chicago Hunter initially stayed at the
Northwestern settlement house and later
at how house the famous settlement
founded by Nobel laureate Jane Addams he
was greatly influenced by Adams and
after remember and other remarkable
leaders of the settlement movement at
that time as was the case with countless
other young college-educated settlement
workers he was transformed from someone
who simply sought to minister to the
poor a do-gooder in other words with a
into a passionate champion of social
reform as he recalled one day the rather
terrifying thought came into my mind
that we were working in a noxious swamp
where almost everyone was being laid low
by malaria racking his brain to remember
how many families he had helped by his
individual relief efforts he was forced
to conclude that there had been precious
few he as he put it it was like swatting
mosquitoes in a malarial swamp and he
went on to conclude there were so few
that I became melancholy over the
prospect of spending the rest of my life
in such fruitless endeavors my efforts I
thought must be directed to some other
end and the real work of my life should
be that of a social engineer intent upon
draining and clearing the swamps well in
Chicago hunter organized the nation's
first municipal shelter for homeless
people and under the tutelage of Adams
wrote a groundbreaking book on slum
housing called tenement conditions in
Chicago published in 1901 as a result of
the reputation that he began to acquire
as an energetic and effective social
reformer he was recruited to be head
resident that is the director of the
University settling in New York City his
skills were immediately put to the test
in New York when he was appointed head
of the campaign committee whose goal was
to outlaw the employment of children and
mines factories and sweatshops under his
tireless leadership New York passed the
nation's first effective child labor
laws which became models for the rest of
the country
wellhow house was America's best-known
settlement house the university
settlement was older and more
prestigious having Roosevelt's and
Rockefellers among its patrons and
active participants it was here that
Robert met his future bride Caroline
despite good
despite the press's reaction to the
marriage when it was announced which
took place in 1903 he actually Adam the
match was actually approved by
Caroline's family and seems to be
enacted actively encouraged by
Caroline's mother who included the young
couple in a
small group that she took for a trip to
the Grand Canyon and private railroad
car the newlyweds had planned to spend
their honeymoon in England where Roberts
had friends from a previous visit in
1899
however it turned into quite remarkable
an unconventional honeymoon sometimes
accompanied by car line and sometimes
alone
Hunter spent much of this time in
England meeting with socialists and
other leftist thinkers and politicians
he also visited organisations that
attempted to boot socialist principles
into practice the proximity to England
of other European countries that
promised to provide similar or perhaps
even more instructive examples of social
reform thinking and action were too
tempting for Robert to pass up therefore
their itinerary was extended to include
among other things a visit to Leo toys
Tolstoy at his country estate in Russia
visits to Gore Jewish communities and
the pale of settlement between Russia
and Poland and visits to locations where
they could see Germany's comprehensive
social welfare system in action if you
look at this picture
Caroline looks a little less sparkling
than she did and they pre-wedding
photographs and maybe that's because she
actually was sick not surprisingly got
sick during this traipse across Europe
and they had to spend three weeks for
her to rest in Warsaw before continuing
their travels this photograph was taken
in Berlin actually but they rested up in
Warsaw cause Robert took the opportunity
in Warsaw 200
Polish partisans who were promoting
independence from Russia were presently
ruled that word at that time rule Poland
some of those folks that he met during
that time leader became presidents of
the Polish Republic during the time that
I became independent in the early part
of the century at any rate it was an
interesting honeymoon trip upon the
returned to New York Roberts book
poverty was published and it caused a
sensation opening Americans eyes for the
first time to the existence of
widespread poverty in the midst of
unprecedented wealth he estimated that
at least ten million and maybe as many
as 20 million people did not have a
sufficient food clothing or shelter to
maintain a minimal level of health and
productivity even more significantly he
presented convincing evidence that the
great majority of the poor were poor
through no fault of their own that most
poverty was socially caused and
preventable by appropriate government
action this was revolutionary thinking
of the time and made hunter a national
authority on social problems
HUL said poverty should be read by every
wealthy American and a New York Times
reviewer said it should have a million
readers hundreds advice was sought by
the nation's political and civic leaders
including President Theodore Roosevelt
who invited him to the house the White
House for consultation it also propelled
him into the ranks of the social and
cultural elite of the day resulting in
close friendships with Mark Twain Jack
London John Dewey Upton Sinclair and
others of like mind the conclusions that
flowed from poverty but are that is
the need for safe workplaces sanitary
housing workers compensation widows
pensions unemployment insurance and a
ban on child labor fell far short of
calling for America's Transport
transformation into a socialist society
in fact many of these social reforms
that hunter advocated soon became
central to the platforms of the newly
formed Progressive Party that Theodore
Roosevelt led as well as the progressive
wings of the Republican and Democratic
parties many of these reforms were
adopted actually adopted by individual
states and localities and served as
models for the national programs that
were later enacted under Franklin
Roosevelt's New Deal nevertheless hunter
almost immediately joined the Socialist
Party because he along with an
astonishing cross-section of Americans
thought that it offered the best hope of
achieving the type of society they
believed this was a period the first two
decades of the 20th century the only
period in American history when
socialism was viewed as an acceptable if
not entirely respectable alternative to
the major political parties which had
become to be seen by hunter and others
as being totally controlled by big money
they by the Mellon's the Morgans the
Rockefellers and the carnies and at that
time the people that Teddy Roosevelt
called the malefactors of great wealth
so they joining the Socialist Party and
that particular time was not that
unusual for people even people of means
its membership included not only trade
unionists and intellectuals but also
religious leaders committed to the
social gospel a fair sprinkling of the
middle class and even a few millionaires
like hunter as he was by that time and
his brother-in-law Graham felt Stokes
could we take a look at that family
photograph of the Phelps Stokes family
this is the family that Robert hunter
married into sitting in the middle is
Anson Phelps Stokes one of the richest
men in America but also sitting in that
family photo or a number of socialists
Roberts not they're probably working to
finish up in poverty but sitting down on
the right hand corner is Caroline a
member of the Socialist Party with
Robert jr. in her on her lap and behind
them second from the right is Caroline's
brother Graham Phelps Stokes also a
millionaire also a leader of the
Socialist Party of America next to
Maryam is his wife Rose Pastore Stokes
Rose was an immigrant from Russia
Jewish immigrant from Russia who worked
for many years as a cigar factory worker
in Cleveland before moving to New York
to be a writer for the New York Jewish
Daily News and while covering a story
for the newspaper she interviewed Graham
Phelps Stokes they were smitten with
each other and got married so here we
have a number of socialists she was a
socialist before she married Graham but
here we have a number of socialists in a
very prominent very wealthy American
family of the begin
of the last century hunter rose quickly
to a position of leadership in the party
being twice elected to the National
Executive Committee he also ran as a
socialist for the New York State
Assembly
in 1907 and for believe it or not
governor of Connecticut in 1910 these
were unsuccessful campaign campaigns but
others socialist candidates were as
successful in elective office including
mayor's quite a number of state
legislators and even a couple of us
congressmen while he was active in the
Socialist Party he travelled to Europe
as a delegate to socialist congresses
and while studying the revolutionary
movements that were going on at that
time and that brought him in contact
with such folks as Lenin Trotsky Tolstoy
as I noted and Maxim Gorky Benito
Mussolini
when Melissa Mussolini was an official
of the Italian Socialist Party George
Bernard Shaw and HG Wells his accounts
of these encounters and his writings
make fascinating reading his friendships
and conflicts with such American
socialist leaders as the UT Eugene Debs
the perennial much-beloved and perennial
socialist candidate for president Samuel
Gompers the longtime leader of the
American Federation of Labor Rose pastor
Stokes when we've seen here his
sister-in-law and Emma Goldman the
anarchist socialist and big bill Haywood
word leader of the International Workers
of the world the Wobblies as they were
called
are also intriguing hunter claimed that
among his most important contributions
to the Socialist Party was to persuade a
tired and exhausted Deb's to run for
president for a third time in 1908 this
blocked the threatened candidacy of
Heyward to lead the socialist ticket a
situation that in view and the view of
hunter and her other party moderates
would have been a disaster for the
socialist cause on account of he words
militancy struggles between those like
hunter and Deb's
who favored gradual societal change
through democratic processes and those
like he would who were willing to use
any means necessary including violence
to bring about the desired revolution
began to undermine Hunter's health and
and actually his faith in the socialist
cause when World War one came the
Socialist Party of America was virtually
destroyed by the conflicts over
America's entry into the war and the Red
Scare that followed Deb's and rose
pasture storks spokes and many others
receive prison sentences for their
opposition to the war and I just
disillusioned Robert hunter resigned
from the party and moved to California
for health health reasons he continued
to be to study the ways in which
societies might organize themselves to
achieve fairness and prosperity for all
the citizens as book-y we fail as
Christians published in 1919 reflected
on his an ongoing quest to find a way to
live one's life and full accord with
one's religious beliefs the impulses
that land him from an early age to live
in accordance with his these religious
principles continued to innovate animate
him
in this book he wondered how Christians
in a society of their own making can
observe without pain or protest poverty
slums child labor low wages long hours
and all the known evils of our
industrial life during the 1920s once he
had moved to California hunter pursued a
passion that was somewhat at odds with
the with his championship of the world's
poor and oppressed at a time when golf
was exclusively a past he knows are very
wealthy he wrote a pioneering book on
golf court design called the Linx
originally published in 1926 it was
destined to become a classic when new
editions still finding their way into
print today the last one I found was
print published in 1999 in addition to
this remarkable and enduring
contribution to the theory of golf
course design
he created along with his partner Dolls
dr. Alistair McKenzie some of the best
golf courses in California most notably
the Cypress Point Club at Pebble Beach
which is consistently ranked among the
best and most beautiful golf courses in
the world I'm going to stop at this
point I can go on further and we'll fill
in more details of the later parts of
Hunter's life if people are interested
but I'd like to pause and give folks an
opportunity to comment on what I've said
so far or or ask questions there may be
a reluctance to bring the ice with
questions and I can go on a little bit
toward the end of his life while still
committee to speaking of for for the
disadvantaged and the dispossessed he
became a bit more conserve
he continued to study revolutionary
movements in Europe primarily and was
utterly dismayed by the unintended
consequences of those movements
particularly the dictatorships of the
right and the left that emerged in in
Europe the dictatorship of the left in
the case of vast Allanon in Russia
and in reaction the dictatorships of
Mussolini and Hitler and Germany in
reaction to the to the revolutionary
movements and therefore he concluded
that revolutions were dangerous because
you couldn't predict the outcome and he
wrote a very important book just to year
and that was published just two years
before he died published in 1940 called
revolution and any of he analyzed those
processes in Europe and came to the
conclusion that that capitalism for all
of its faults and it had many many
faults and he laid them out in great
detail in in revolution but despite
those faults it probably was the best
system for ensuring people's Liberty and
and ultimately for their prosperity
simultaneously with the publication of
the revolution he actively campaigned
for will Wayne Wendell Willkie which
some of you may remember was the
Republican opponent to Franklin
Roosevelt in in 1940 Roosevelt was
running for an unprecedented third term
as as past president and lots of folks
including Hunter were war
that you know he was going to be
president for life maybe he was going to
be following in the style the the steps
of the the dictators and Europe meant in
our present minds that signs a bit
exaggerated an alarmist but there were
people who were genuinely concerned
about that and so hunter res supporting
Wendell Willkie and his unsuccessful
effort to rest up the third term of
their of Reserva questions/comments put
everybody to sleep yes sir there is a
microphone there if you would like thank
you
excellent question how did hunter relate
to religious leaders of the time and he
actually was very continued to be you
know a Christian a lot of people think
this is very strange
how a person who's a devoted Christian
could at some point ally himself with
socialists many of whom were you who
believed that religion was the opiate of
the masses
you know not Sarah was put by some of
the more radical socialists of the time
so there is a question know her how did
he maintain his religious belief how did
it play out in his work on behalf of the
poor and how did it relate or there are
other religious leaders of the time well
he was very close to many of the leaders
of what was called the social group and
gospel movement that I mentioned and
these were people of religion who
believed very strongly that the country
the US was headed in the wrong direction
that that what was being played out in
on the national scene was the pursuit of
partner self-interest the pursuit of
greed the disregard for the poor among
us and that something needed to be done
about it
now lots of people involved in the
religious community were very active in
providing relief to the poor you know
making sure that people got food if they
were hungry provided shelter if they
could possibly provide it and clothing
and everything else that they were
capable of doing but the people in the
social gospel movement thought that it
was necessary to go beyond simply
offering handouts to the needy they saw
that that was insufficient and didn't
meet people's needs beyond the immediate
emergency what was needed was a reform
of the system so that it would be more
fair and would be in fact more in accord
with the teachings of all of the major
religions most of the folks active at
that time were you know
you know people of the Christian faith
in the US both Protestants and Catholics
but also there was a significant
movement in the Jewish community to
respond to these kinds of meats for
example I mentioned the the settlement
movement there were many Jewish
settlements that were active in the
major cities of the of the I was a and
Northeast and Midwest who are attempting
to address these kind of things so
Hunter was a you know an ally didn't
belong formally to the social gospel
movement